the police timeline of what happened
when at the shooting in texas last week
continues to change and both police and
the school district have stopped
cooperating with the texas probe raising
all sorts of questions
about what on earth happened including
some less than helpful speculation and
we'll talk about all of it
if there's one thing that we can be sure
of
if any
talking point has been brutally
destroyed by what happened in texas last
week it's the idea of the good guy with
the gun as the solution to bad guys with
guns that has been utterly and
completely destroyed but we still have
to figure out what is going on and why
it is not only that the police and
school district have stopped cooperating
with the texas investigation
but why the timeline put out there by
police continues to change there's a cnn
article addressing this as the funerals
continue authority's timeline of the
terror at robb elementary school
continues to shift
continues to shift
the texas department of public safety
now says the door the shooter used to
access the school was closed but not
locked when he entered before killing 21
people there that's a change from last
week when the department's director said
the back door had been propped open by a
teacher turns out that apparently wasn't
true
on tuesday its spokesperson told the ap
the teacher closed the door once she
realized the shooter was on campus but
the door did not lock
the department's press secretary
confirmed yesterday to cnn that the ap
report was accurate
tuesday's clarification represents just
one of the shifts in authority's
explanations of the massacres timeline
they face mounting questions over why 80
minutes we've at first thought it was 40
to 60. we now know 80 minutes elapsed
from the time officers were called to
the moment a tactical team entered the
lot classrooms and killed the gunman
um
these are
sort of like the main changes so far
and also uh important and unclear why
and we're going to talk about this more
on the bonus show is this question of
why the cooperation has stopped abc news
reporting
uvalde police school district no longer
cooperating with texas probe of shooting
the police department and independent
school district police force are no
longer cooperating with the texas
department of public safety's
investigation into the massacre at the
elementary school multiple law
enforcement sources tell abc
the uvalde police chief and spokesperson
for the school district did not
immediately respond for request for
comment
according to sources the decision to
stop cooperating occurred soon after the
directors of dps
the director of dps held a news
conference friday during which he said
the delayed police entry into the
classroom was the wrong decision and
contrary to protocol
something clearly is going on here now
there are some who are going way beyond
what the facts show i even started to
see i hesitate to even mention this but
i think it's important to mention with
the with the note that there's no
evidence of this that some are saying
this is evidence that it might have
actually been police that killed some of
the victims there is no evidence of that
at this point in time absolutely none
but the point is to let you know how far
some are going in interpreting the halt
to the cooperation the most likely
scenario is also the most obvious
scenario which is the response was
bungled
the good guys with the guns didn't go in
at least partially because they were
afraid of being shot with which i
sympathize with which i sympathize but
the whole point of having police is that
they are the good guys with guns to stop
the bad guys with guns and waiting 80
minutes is not the way the system is
supposed to work but i
listen
who wouldn't be afraid of getting shot
if there's a a gunman with multiple
assault rifles going crazy that part
makes sense the response does not uh
that's the most likely explanation that
it was mishandled and they tried to stay
one step ahead of the questions that
eventually came because their
explanations didn't make sense they
failed to actually stay a step ahead and
now it's all coming down that's the most
likely explanation the speculation is
going to be there regardless but the
most important takeaway here as we get
back to the main thing
is
this is not going to be the problem of
mass shootings is not going to be going
to be resolved by talking about mental
health alone obviously it's not and in
fact we'll later talk about how greg
abbott says it's a mental health issue
but defunded mental health in texas
unbelievable that's not going to solve
it it's not going to be an issue with
doors
and it's certainly not going to be an
issue of more armed people
at some point you're going to have to
deal with the firearms and we will
discuss more about this on today's bonus
show
the real mental health issue
might actually be the republican party
the uh there is a new piece in the new
republic by michael tamaski
called the main mental health issue in
this country
is in the republican party and this
piece makes a number of really good
points
one of the points that the piece makes
and i encourage you to read it is that
red states allocate way less money for
treating mental illness than do blue
states and in fact if you look at a map
and we're putting such a map up on the
screen
you can see that generally speaking red
states are much lighter colored meaning
they devote a much smaller share of
their budgets towards mental health
treatment that we know
and so
at a baseline level this is a bad start
when you look back at the last many
years there is really only been one
major expansion of mental health
spending and coverage
and it's called the affordable care act
also known as obamacare remember
obamacare and the affordable care act
are the same thing i know it's wild that
i have to mention that but i do
um and republicans regularly
vote against all other attempts as i've
talked about with greg abbott or we will
talk about with greg abbott as i talked
about with congressman tony gonzalez
republicans regularly vote against
attempts to increase funding and
increase access to mental health
treatment so at a core level when we say
mental health mental illness
red states are disproportionately
underfunded when it comes to access so
it's a perfectly logical conclusion
you've got more republicans than
democrats in red states
red states have lower funding for mental
health treatment
increasingly mental illness you would
expect would skew towards being a
republican problem at to be clear it
doesn't mean at all
that there aren't millions of lefties
and democrats etc who struggle with
mental illness but when you look at
access and treatment and funding it's
going to skew as a more as a bigger
problem to the right but it's more than
that
the problem
in terms of mental health
isn't just health care
it's also
about economic care
we know about the crushing effect on
one's uh uh mood and cognitive state and
mental health status
of being unable to take time off from
work when you need it
of knowing that you're going to be able
to just pay your basic bills
of uh
feeling like there's no economic
opportunity where you are and when you
look at all of these different things
when you look at right-wing economic
policy versus left-wing economic policy
the economic realities of red states we
know are much more negatively impactful
on mental health and and sort of the
state of one's mood
than those economic policies in blue
leading states again these are averages
we're talking generally
now
there's another layer which tamaski
doesn't talk about in the piece which i
want to add
which is
when we talk about a lot of these right
wing ideas
they sound almost what we might call
mentally ill now i want to be really
careful we we may not literally mean
mentally ill in all of these cases okay
we're not stigmatizing mental illness
we're also not using it as an insult but
when you hear the idea
give teachers guns
and have them defend classrooms
it sounds like what you would say
is an insane idea it's disconnected from
reality only someone who has something
wrong either significant ignorance
or
some kind of mental disturbance would
suggest because it doesn't make any
sense
and we can go further there was a recent
poll 20 percent or more of the
republican party believes at least some
q in on conspiracies okay is it
literally diagnostic mental illness no
it's not but a lot of this ideology
borders on people who are uh
having some kind of block where they're
not connected to the real world
there's a delusional nature to it after
the 2020 election 57 percent of trump
voters believed that trump won trump
didn't win
joe biden won
joe biden easily won the popular vote
joe biden easily won the electoral vote
no one state would have changed that of
the states that were in play trump
didn't win trump lost and yet 57 percent
of his voters believed that he had won
at some point we have to say well
there's a delusional nature to it is it
diagnostically delusional well that
you'd have to examine everybody and
mental health professionals would have
to make the call
but when we talk about mental health
the fact that they're saying well just
fix guns by dealing with fix shootings
by dealing with mental health rather
than guns well at the micro level they
vote against doing that all the time
they don't want to fund mental health
treatment they don't want to do any of
it
but when we say
it's a mental illness problem what are
we really saying and when you step back
and look at the state of american
politics and you look at where access to
mental health treatment is funded and
you look at the delusional nature of a
lot of these ideas again i know i always
use this example we're not talking about
a difference as to whether the top tax
rate should be 20
35 or 50 percent okay that this is a
different thing we're talking about
something that is fundamentally
delusional and you need only look at the
nra convention
you need to only look at the so-called
suggestions that they're coming up with
to deal with the gun violence issue to
see that so i'm not diagnosing anybody
i'm not stigmatizing mental illness and
i'm not ridiculing mental illness i'm
also not using the term mental illness
as a cudgel to attack people with but i
am pointing out that when we talk about
mental illness broadly
we really have to dig into what is
happening state by state to understand
the implications of number one not
properly funding dealing with mental
health issues
and number two pointing to them in some
vague way when we blame shootings but
then all of a sudden we can't say hey
half of the ideas associated with
trumpism are delusional colloquially
um
that i i'm sort of at a a at a loss for
words to go further but i'm very curious
to hear from you what do you think find
me on twitter deepakman and remember
that tuesday june 14th at 6 p.m we'll be
doing our next david pakman show viewer
town hall it will be streaming live
exclusively on the pacman live youtube
channel that's our second youtube
channel subscribe there and we're very
much looking forward to that next town
hall
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is an audience
supported program i would love for you
to sign up at joinpakman.com
and become a member every day we do an
extra show for our members called the
bonus show we also provide a commercial
free audio stream and a commercial free
video stream of the show to our members
and we make the episodes every single
day available to our members sometimes
we sometimes somewhere between five and
six hours earlier than we published the
full video show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code big voting 22 big voting 22
because everyone must vote in november
of course big voting 22 at
joinpakman.com
we want to continue our discussion about
this whole mental health idea we don't
need to deal with guns we just need to
deal with mental health well then it
would follow that we need to actually
make mental health treatment more
accessible
last week we looked at republican texas
congressman tony gonzalez and i played
clips for you of tony gonzalez saying
this is just a mental illness problem
these shootings it's not about guns it's
just about mental illness that's all
that we really have to deal with and
then we looked at tony gonzalez's voting
record when it came to increased access
to health care and it was atrocious
voting against obamacare expansions
voting against all sorts of different
funding for health related programs
because it's just something they want to
say
it's not actually something they want to
deal with well now we have an example of
a republican texas governor greg abbott
at a press conference last week greg
abbott again said the issue here it's
not about guns
it's about mental health here is greg
abbott explaining this so the
the ability of an 18 year old to
buy a long gun
has been in place in the state of texas
for more than 60 years
and
think about during the time over the
course of that 60 years
we have not had episodes like this now
texas actually has a pretty big mass
shooting problem
but one of the things that has changed
even if they want to make the case well
the access to guns hasn't necessarily
changed in the last 60 years
the marketing to people
to get more and more guns has changed
over 60 years but importantly the
culture around guns has changed over 60
years where because of this corrosive
american gun culture
and the educational problems and
the almost
uh
the delusional nature of the american
right
more and more people come to see
firearms as a way to solve problems
that's a cultural issue so things have
changed but now we're getting to the key
part
and why why is it that for the majority
of those 60 years
we did not have
school shootings
and why is it that we do now the reality
is i don't know the answer to that
question
however
what i do know in in talking to the
leaders here
as well as leaders in other locations
around the state
and that is one thing that has
substantially changed
is the status of mental health in our
communities
what i do know is this
and that is
we as a state we as a society
need to do a better job with mental
health
anybody
who shoots somebody else
has a mental health challenge
period
we have we as a government
need to find a way
to
target that mental health challenge
right
now the issue with all of this is as
usual there's massive hypocrisy
greg abbott cut
211
million dollars from a mental health
commission there's a report on ksat
which says um abbott has doubled down on
his stance that mass shootings are an
issue of mental health and not gun
access however in april abbott slashed
nearly
211 million dollars from the health and
human services commission which oversees
mental health services in texas abbott
diverted the funds to add to his effort
to send national guard to the texas
mexico border
known as operation lone star no other
texas agency received a more significant
cut
than the hhsc when abbott slashed
funding
texas ranks 44th in the united states
for an overall ranking of mental health
measures and last out of all 50 states
in access to mental health care
the republican right
never pays a political price for their
hypocrisy and that has to change
but think about the absurdity of this
the problem isn't guns it's mental
health
well okay i mean to a degree
we've been talking about the problems
there for a long time although there's a
cultural problem as well we gotta figure
out how to deal with mental health oh
well how would we do that
i don't know i cut funding to expand
mental health care in my state which is
already dead last on access to mental
health care to instead use the money to
send national guard to the texas mexico
border
that's you know and of course
unless their constituents are able to
follow and understand and be aware of
this there's not going to be any
accountability there simply isn't it's
it
it's not a crazy thing to think a voter
could understand okay let's see
maybe guns are part of it maybe they
aren't but if mental health care is a
part of it then what is greg abbott
doing to deal with that actually he's
making the problem worse by defunding it
to send national guard to the border oh
i should vote against him i should vote
for better o'rourke
i should you know would it stay home but
i shouldn't go and vote for greg abbott
if that's the case
but they don't hold themselves to the
standards which they
appear to try
to hold the left to
and at this point conservatism
fundamentally is about there are in
groups and there are out groups and it
doesn't matter what aspect of our
politics we're talking about we must
protect the in-groups at all costs at
the expense of the out-groups even if we
are openly hypocritical openly
hypocritical well uh it when when it
comes to immigration
well we must protect the in-group which
is the natural-born american citizens or
whatever when it comes to
uh religion the in-group is christians
when it comes to you you understand the
idea here and whatever principle they
state
is going to be ignored
when it would no longer protect whatever
the in-group is at the time
and mental health now is the issue
in order to protect the gun owners and
not have to do anything about the guns
but we're not actually going to deal
with the mental health issue when we
have opportunities to fund it we take
money away don't you dare use my tax
money to help solve that problem we're
pro-life right
but don't you dare use my tax money
to improve foster care
or to help single mothers
or to fund comprehensive sex education
which reduces the demand for abortions
no no no no no
this is a sickness
i mean listen even look at police right
oh police are always right and we must
support them always when there's some
police use of force against often it's a
non-white person but then all of a
sudden well look at what happened look
at how the police were treated on
january 6. no no no now the police are
bad and the justice system is bad
because the in-group the trumpists are
sitting in pre-trial detention it's
there are no actual principles that go
beyond
supporting the in-group and we are very
much seeing that here
an nra convention attendee was brutally
fact checked on video completely
disproven in real time and still says
well i still believe the same thing
this is an incredible
epistemologically instructive event this
is from our friends over at the good
liars who are doing such good work the
good liars are davrum stifler
and jason selvig
this is a great example about how
confronting people with facts is useless
in the face of their worldview and their
pre-existing notions if the facts
support their conclusion they'll use the
facts if the facts contradict their
conclusion they'll ignore the facts or
say the facts don't matter or that it's
fake news or whatever check this out uh
you
this is just unbelievable more people
and more crime is committed and more
people are killed with hammers every
year than guns
look at the facts i i will look that up
i don't think that's true actually it's
true in the united states though sir
that is true look it up it's on you can
google it
it's true it's actually true
so the number of murder victims and the
weapons used okay number one
handguns
8029 number two firearms type not stated
4863
number three knives are cutting
instruments personal weapons
fists feet
uh then rifles
at 455 then blunt objects clubs hammers
uh
393. the the 300 the hammers that that
stat is just wrong back to your question
second amendment is still my right and
it's still important to me
notice how confident this guy is in
something that is not only obviously
wrong
but verifiably wrong and verified to his
face and notice how quickly he abandons
it as instructive and informative to his
opinion
going in
part of his support for firearms was
hammers are much more deadly he's then
shown hammers are not much more deadly
the fact is completely debunked but now
his opinion is no longer based on that
now it's just it's in the second
amendment and that's it so the format of
this if we wanted to kind of um uh
boil this down to a kind of fundamental
logic the format is
here's something i made up
that supports my conclusion well but
that thing isn't true you just invented
that and it's wrong and then yes but it
actually doesn't matter and i still
believe the same thing because it didn't
really make a difference to my opinion
oh okay by the way
think about hammers for a second okay
imagine that we took away all the
hammers
all right
wouldn't deaths for deaths from hammers
go down
they almost certainly would but people
might replace the hammer with something
else like a gun well
if those looking to pil kill people with
hammers instead get a gun they'll
probably be able to kill more people do
any of us disagree with that no the the
gun is much more deadly than the hammer
well then why isn't the opposite true
right if we take away the guns wouldn't
deaths from guns go down and they would
say yeah but they might get something
else like a hammer well you're going to
kill way fewer people with a hammer than
with a gun they it's sort of like the
logic is accepted by almost everyone
when you go hammered a gun
if you hand someone a hammer versus a
gun who are they most likely to be how
many people are they most likely be able
to kill people accept it going one
direction but when you say well if
everybody was if the mass shooters all
had swords
wouldn't they kill fewer people no
they'd still figure out a way to kill
just as many people because the guns
aren't really a factor what
that doesn't make any sense makes no
sense at all so an incredibly
instructive moment
remember the facts only matter if they
are convenient and if they aren't
convenient they no longer matter we'll
have this clip on our instagram page
which you can find at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show so republican texas
senator ted cruz continues to say almost
downright sinister things about gun
safety most recently saying that if
there were no guns in america
the number of murders would actually go
up huh how is that possible we'll talk
about it here's the clip ted cruz on his
i guess he has a podcast now called
verdict
it's a very weird and deranged program
but let's listen to what ted cruz had to
say see if you can make sense out of
this
taking away every firearm that michael
knowles owns would not have stopped this
psychopath
from murdering children in uvalde
and by the way we see that
in chicago and new york and dc and
california where they have very strict
gun control yeah and the criminals still
have guns and still carry out murders if
you could wave a magic wand
and eliminate all firearms in america
there would be substantially more
murders than there are today that is an
absolutely nutty comment if you could
wave a magic wand and eliminate all
firearms in america there would be
substantially more murders
think about it on an incident by
incident basis imagine
this particular shooter in texas
the shooter
maybe would have killed someone but the
odds are that without a gun he doesn't
kill nearly as many people i've never
heard of an incident to go back to our
earlier good liars segment where someone
kills 20 people with a hammer
i've never heard of an incident
in which police armed police
i assume in ted cruz's vision the police
still have firearms where armed police
don't go in to confront a knife-wielding
attacker for 80 minutes because they're
afraid i've just never heard of that now
remember we're doing imaginary stuff if
you could wave a wand and if waving the
wand actually eliminated all the
firearms how on earth would there be
more murders it is a logical
impossibility
now it's also remember uh important to
remember
that the rate of firearm homicides per
hundred thousand people
is off the charts in the united states
you look at what we're putting this up
this is from the ihme
in the u.s the rate of firearm homicides
per hundred thousand people is just over
four
you then have chile just under two and
then a whole bunch of countries at
either 0.5 or lower you know a lot of
these places
uh
spain
0.13 firearm homicides per 100 000
people the uk which has very strict gun
control
0.045
homicides per 100 000 people the major
difference is we have the most guns now
do a lot of these countries have better
access to mental health care yes many of
them do
do many of these countries not have the
toxic and depraved american gulf gun
culture yes many of them don't have that
but the biggest difference is the number
of firearms in the civilian population
per capita
and you see
the uh outcome of that in the rate of
firearms homicides and the major
difference is we have the most guns
apply ted cruz's logic to almost
everything else well if you eliminated
all cars
you would end up with more traffic
fatalities well hold on how how would
that work that doesn't make any sense
maybe if you eliminated all cars you'd
end up with i don't know more deaths
from heart attack because there'd be no
vehicles to take people to emergency
rooms oh okay well
that's plausible and we could explore
whether it's true
and much the same way if you waved a
magic wand and eliminated all guns
maybe the number of murders from other
things would go up but relative to the
number of murders that can so easily be
done with high-powered firearms the
number of murders would certainly go
down and uh at this point they're just
they're not even thinking
realistically in any way they're just
they're just not it's just not it's not
we're not operating in the real world
anymore and they will say absolutely
anything
hey this is the best donald trump
flipped out because a jury has acquitted
hillary clinton's lawyer this if you
haven't been following this story
this is the absolute best former hillary
clinton campaign attorney michael
sussman has been acquitted of lying to
the fbi about donald trump and russia
during the 2016 election
this was supposed to be the big smoking
gun trump was talking about this others
have been talking about this with regard
to the 2016 election we were finally
going to get the proof of everything
hillary did to me during my campaign as
trump liked to say and the verdict
indeed
is that uh mr sussman has been acquitted
a clinton campaign lawyer michael
sussman found not guilty of lying to the
fbi in a blow to the durham
investigation trump's been talking about
this durham investigation for months and
months and months a hillary clinton
campaign lawyer michael sussman was
acquitted of lying to the fbi the first
trial of special counsel john durham's
investigation the verdict is a major
defeat for durham and as justice
department prosecutors who have spent
three years looking for wrongdoing in
the trump-russia probe he claimed
sussman lied during a 2016 meeting in
which he passed a tip to the fbi about
trump and russia the jury deliberated
for six hours over two days and revolt
and uh uh reached a verdict
the case revolved around
uh sussman's 2016 meeting with james
baker a friend who was the fbi's general
counsel sussman passed along a tip which
led to a four-month fbi inquiry into a
possible internet back channel between
the trump organization and the
kremlin-linked alpha bank both companies
denied the claim the fbi found no
improper cyber links so here is uh
sussman speaking about the verdict and
then i'm going to show you how trump
flipped out i have a few thoughts to
share now the trial has ended
first
i told the truth to the fbi
and the jury clearly recognized that
with their unanimous verdict today
i'm grateful to the members of the jury
for their careful and thoughtful service
despite being falsely accused i'm
relieved that justice ultimately
prevailed in my case so this is called
due process
and trump
absolutely flips out on his platform
truth social truth essential saying our
legal system is corrupt our judges and
justices are highly partisan compromised
or just plain scared our borders are
open our elections are rigged inflation
is rampant gas prices and food costs are
through the roof our military leadership
is woke our country is going to hell
and michael sussman is not guilty
how's everything else doing
enjoy your day
this was a jury that acquitted him this
was the people if they are for law and
order and due process
then this man is not guilty due process
has taken place it has been adjudicated
remember when trump said that durham's
case was going to be bigger than
watergate and it was going to expose the
biggest political crime of the century
which when asked trump said you know
what it is he wouldn't even say what it
was obama gate
none of these things are anything and
fox news immediately running with the oh
the jury the jury the jury was in dc it
was a bad jury this is due process and
they don't like the outcome take a look
at this but it was given the auspice of
being true not because of a media report
but because of an fbi investigation into
president trump and at the center of
that was this sussman meeting um and
michael sussman the prosecutor in this
case britain shaw argued that he wanted
a quote october surprise that that was
at the the heart of his intentions it
doesn't appear that the jury bought that
but i think david spunt raises a key
point harris the dc jury pool this is a
area of our country where 76 percent of
people in the district of columbia are
registered democrat this was a jury pool
of 37 that was whittled down to a
smaller number but of those 37 jurors
there were many about clinton supporters
who said they had donated to the clinton
campaign
some of those individuals weren't chosen
but about a third of that jury pool was
either a clinton supporter or had strong
feelings about the election
listen
in every case
in the written house case in in any case
there's always
some beliefs on the jury
that might
superficially seem in some way
adversarial to one side or the other but
we have a process for jury selection
during which people are asked do you
think you can fairly evaluate the facts
and if the facts point this way or that
way you would be able to and people say
yes i would or no i wouldn't it's the
same jury selection process you have
anywhere
and this is an absurd post-hoc
justification um and prosecutors were
very frustrated that they would not get
a fair shake here so i think this does
raise questions on how fair of a shake
you could be given in dc with the jury
pool that does oftentimes weigh
partisanly in one direction you can't
prosecute republicans in washington d.c
washington d.c is let me see washington
d.c
republic uh democrat
percentage
um
i guess it's like roughly 70 something
percent i mean you ca no republican
uh led prosecution
uh and no democratic
um defendant can be fairly evaluated
because there's just too many democrats
in washington dc this is essentially
what they are saying these people are
shameless
they are only concerned with the
consequences this is the due process
they they claim to be about this is the
law and order they claim to be about the
durham investigation was allowed to
happen nobody interfered with it they
were able to bring charges they were
able to show we have at least probable
cause or suff probable cause maybe is
the wrong term the the a judge said
there's enough here to move forward and
have a trial
you got a jury prosecution and defense
were allowed to evaluate the jury they
settled on a jury they had the trial
they had deliberations they had a
verdict
it was in dc of course he was acquitted
of course he was acquitted they will
never be satisfied with law and order
if it doesn't give them the outcome that
they want
and uh i mean is this it for for the
durham probe probably not
but we are going to continue to follow
it it's not feeling like the durham
investigation is going to expose the
so-called biggest crime of the century
it's it's not my sense that that's the
direction that it's going let me know
we'll be posting these stories on our
facebook page facebook.com
david pakman show we'll take a quick
break and be back right after this
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
we knew it would eventually happen and a
fox news host is now blaming cannabis
for mass shootings and specifically for
the shooting last week in texas
why wouldn't they eventually get the
cannabis they've blamed everything else
other than guns they blamed coveted
masks they blamed video games
they blamed doors they blamed mental
illness they blamed coveted lockdowns
and the isolation that comes from it
they blamed wokeness they blamed i know
i'm forgetting some things but
it makes sense that they would
eventually get to cannabis and that's
now what they are talking about so let's
look at this clip of fox news host laura
ingram and look at the effort
she goes through in order to point the
finger
at cannabis here and we're going to talk
about it this is from last night's show
there's a lot here so we'll do our best
to keep up with all of it and speaking
of drugs according to the daily mail
well the new york times had originally
reported that ramos smoked pot
then mysteriously the reference was
missing from the online editions
now why is that
was it bad information
or is this the pro-marijuana bias that
we've become accustomed to
that's so powerful because billions are
on the line with it nationwide
so is the story now irrelevant
we reached out to the times on this
but they have not responded
now
when it we're going to keep going with
this
when it comes specifically to the texas
shooter one of the important questions
would be okay
we can talk about cannabis but if you're
going to make a claim about cannabis
are you
arguing that
the cannabis made him go and buy the
guns
like was he high and decided to go buy
the guns because he was high
or are you saying that
the guns were purchased with a clear
mind
but then smoking pot made him say well
now i'm going to go and do a shooting
was he high all the time or like
one of the issues when people do this
stuff that laura ingram's doing is what
is even the claim that you're making
let's see if she makes one now the
american people are hearing a lot about
ar-15s and background checks
but they also deserve to hear about this
as well
respected medical studies for years now
have demonstrated that pot use
especially among teens
can trigger psychosis and increase the
chance that a young person will develop
violent behaviors
now
let's say that that's true and we're
gonna get eventually to the science on
all of this if that were true
it would be great like let's say you're
laura ingram okay i'm buying into what
she says
if that's true
it would be great to have the
opportunity to know
hey
this person smokes pot we shouldn't let
them buy guns well how would you do that
one way would be to have an initial and
periodic mental health evaluation and
during which people are asked about drug
use
and
requiring for people under age 25 who
want to buy firearms
requiring letters of sort of uh
recommendation as it were
from adults in the community
and it would give you an opportunity to
find out if this is someone who smokes
pot now i'm not even saying if you smoke
pot you should or shouldn't be able to
get a gun i'm merely saying if her
concern
is that people who smoke pot not be
allowed to have guns
then why not put in some of the systems
i mentioned last week to allow us to
figure that out well but she's against
that so even this
is not something they are genuinely
committed to but let's continue
the association of mature american
citizens right
a 2017 study identified marijuana as the
single most common correlative variable
in otherwise diverse populations and
circumstances surrounding the
association of violence and marijuana
now
correlative is an important word because
as we know correlations and causations
are two different things but we'll get
back to that
reported links exist to shooters in
parkland el paso dayton aurora colorado
tucson chattanooga sacramento and
perhaps elsewhere
now a friend of the dayton shooter conor
betts told authorities that he was a gun
owner and that he had done hard drugs
with bets as well as marijuana and acid
four or five times a week now that's
essentially meaningless in drawing
drawing causation hard drugs and
marijuana and acid well it's kind of
hard to blame the marijuana in that case
isn't it from 2014 to 2015.
former new york times reporter alex
berenson has written extensively on okay
alex berenson is is a joke and so i'm
gonna i'm gonna pause this here so this
is actually really tricky because there
are actually two questions the first
question is
physiologically does using cannabis make
people more people more violent either
while they are under the influence or
in a future
moment even when not actively under the
influence so there's a physiological
question
separately
there's the question of is obtaining
cannabis associated with violence and
what i mean by that is one issue could
be
the physical interaction of cannabis thc
or cbd with the body does that cause
someone to become violent but another
would be
because the cannabis market is still a
black market in many places for
recreational cannabis
does being around a black market of drug
dealing put you near violent situations
that's that's another question which you
would really have to take seriously
these are dramatically different
questions now i'm giving laura ingram
too much credit because i'm pretending
she's like honestly talking about this
which obviously she's not
ingram cites a piece by the association
of mature american citizens that's just
a right-wing lobby it doesn't they don't
do
it it's just an advocacy group that's a
right-wing group
we have good studies on
the link
between cannabis and violence
and it is true
that a number of studies have found a
slight correlation
between violent behavior
among cannabis users that's absolutely
true there's i mean it's just what it is
i have no interest in denying that
they have not been able to establish any
causality at this point and additionally
it hasn't been established that cannabis
makes people not predisposed to violence
any more violent and that's a critical
thing
lastly there's no evidence i was able to
find that cannabis use makes people more
likely to commit crimes
we could imagine a scenario
where one's threshold for aggressive
behavior might be lowered by cannabis
hypothetically but that doesn't mean
that it's going to take someone not
predisposed or interested in committing
crimes and make them go and commit
crimes because they're high but of
course it's the typical double standard
because the correlation between alcohol
and crime is off the charts the
correlation between alcohol and domestic
violence is completely off the charts
compared to cannabis it's a widely
established link
and fox never talks about it because
it's not convenient laura did a bunch on
this yesterday she then brought on some
guy let's see if we can figure out who
this guy is um saying why aren't people
more more people talking about this pot
thing it was initially reported that he
was a user in fact he got angry that his
grandmother and his mother didn't want
him to use marijuana but again we don't
know more it was just mysteriously taken
out of an article in the new york times
but why aren't people in general not
talking more about the pot psychosis
violent behavior uh connection
well that's a very good question
okay uh but last thought on this explain
this to me
it's not the guns it's the people so
there's no sense in banning any guns
but
it is the drugs not the people and so we
should ban drugs i mean that doesn't
seem to make too much sense to me either
science aside so there's laura ingraham
with her new shiny toy and that shiny
toy is cannabis hey i love it when these
wacky right wingers turn on each other
and donald trump is now furious with
kellyanne conway his longtime adviser
kellyanne conway has now made a number
of statements which have infuriated
donald trump there's a politico article
about this former president donald trump
is denying a key anecdote from kellyanne
conway's book
saying he would have banished kellyanne
from his inner circle if she had ever
told him he lost the 2020 presidential
election so what's that issue here
is that kellyanne conway has now uh
kellyanne conway wrote
i had already said publicly what i'd
said privately to george his daily daily
oh this actually isn't the right thing
so where where is this here um
it might not the quote might actually
not be in this article kellyanne conway
writes in her book among other things
that she was one of the first people to
tell trump you lost you just you lost
and that's it you lost the election
and trump is now saying that that's not
true trump posted on his platform truth
social truth essential quote kellyanne
conway never told me that she thought we
lost the election
if she had i wouldn't have dealt with
her any longer she would have been wrong
could go back to her crazy husband
kellyanne conway's husband is anti-trump
republican george conway
uh back to the quote
writing books can make people say some
very strange things i wonder why got 12
million more votes than we did the first
time the most votes by far of any
sitting president the election was
rigged they used covid to cheat and
steal
and the evidence is massive and
indisputable
c
20 thousand two thousand mules which of
course is the completely bogus and
widely debunked dinesh d'souza i can't
even call it a documentary because it
doesn't document anything real let's
call it a compilation of audio-visual
elements he's now promoting 2000 mules
as evidence so there's a few different
things going on here first of all it's
great when they fight amongst themselves
it weakens them generally speaking we
should encourage it that's number one
number two when you lose even kellyanne
conway you have to start considering
that this might be the end of the grift
to some degree
but at this point trump won't let go of
this until he dies he it's just and we
don't know how long he's going to live
but he is clearly not going to let go of
this false claim that he actually won
and that no one around him was really
saying that you lost
he is going to stick with this until he
dies he had the opportunity as i've said
before
to come out of the pandemic
easily be re-elected okay
all he had to do was say folks
covet is real covet is scary
and we as americans
are going to come together
we're going to be patriotic we're going
to have trump masks we're going to have
american flag and mega masks i'm going
to be wearing them we should all wear
them
we're going to deal with this better
than anybody we've got the best doctors
and we've got the best university you
know but just
right take that approach
and we need to give our medical
community time to develop the treatments
and vaccines that they are going to
develop
let's do it let's do it together that's
all trump had to do
the left would have done it
the right would have gone with it if
their cult leader said it
instead
he was divisive
he would uh blatantly
shun and ignore
public health precautions
he almost ended up dead i mean look at
how seriously sick with covet he ended
up being he would talk about injecting
bleach
he would attack dr fauci
he would um
talk about china you know on and on and
on
he could have easily been re-elected if
he just took it even slightly seriously
and said i am going to be the best on
covid not 15 cases will soon be zero not
ignore everything not we need our
freedom or any of this stuff
just follow the protocols we're gonna
get through this and you couldn't do it
it's sort of like when he was given the
softballs of denouncing cuinon or
denouncing white supremacy and nazis and
instead blames both sides or says he
doesn't know about it or doubles down or
whatever the case may be this guy was
given
these these were just teed up for him to
knock out of the park and he couldn't do
it and now the situation he's in is he
is going to take to his grave the lie
that he actually won the 2020 election
if you think that there is anything that
would get him to admit i just genuinely
lost to biden
i don't know what it would be
but let me know what you think could get
him to admit that
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
this is my new favorite caller
this is a delightful lady from texas
who is very politely correcting me on my
pronunciation of something
i can't think of a a more delightful
recent caller than this check it out
hi david i just wanted to let you know
by the way
the voice cracking on no
is
even more delightful let's listen to it
one more time
hi david i just wanted to let you know
that here in texas we don't say uvalde
we say you valdi it reminds me of you
pal me you know it rhymes
you valdi
please correct
thank you i know you're not from texas
but
that's the way it's pronounced here
uvalde
thank you bye
this is the best caller now i'm going to
admit to you what's going on with my
pronunciation of that town in texas
as many of you know i'm from argentina
okay when i look at that word
l d u-v-a-l-d-e
to me it's in spanish and it's
that's the that's the that's the
pronunciation
any time i just pronounce a word the way
it should be pronounced in spanish like
people write in and they go david oh my
god you're doing that pretentious
pompous thing where
it's sort of like when someone will very
jarringly interrupt what they're saying
to say gonzalez instead of gonzalez
and it's jarring and it's pretentious
and it's pompous don't do that and the
problem with me not just pronouncing it
the way it is which is
is i don't actually know which wrong
pronunciation should i use you valde you
they're all wrong guys right i mean it's
just i need to pick the right incorrect
american anglicized pronunciation
of what we all would know as
in the state of texas all right so i
apologize i throw myself at your mercy
but that is that's my new favorite
caller on the bonus show today the
uvalde police
and the uvalde school district are no
longer cooperating with the texas
investigation into the shooting last
week in uvalde we're going to talk about
what's going on building on the story at
the top of the podcast today the supreme
court has blocked a new texas social
media law from taking effect what's in
the law
and why is it being blocked we will tell
you
and lastly there are more and more
democrats opting to vote in republican
primaries merely to vote against donald
trump's nominee we're going to talk
about whether this is a good idea a
risky idea etc all of those stories and
more on two days bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad well easy alex i
invite you not not to buy any kind of
weird supplements but just to sign up at
joinpakman.com become a member you can
use the coupon code big voting 22 to
save bigly
and we will see you on today's bonus
show or if you're not a member i will
see you back here tomorrow
you